oh my god to be a free man it's uh to be
honest with you it's awesome it's
fantastic
you know I have my beautiful wife next
to me I'm healthy I'm sober back at work
with my best friends on the number one
show on MTV and just living the dream
what has the last week been like since
you got out of prison well the last
eight months I've been dreaming of what
my first days would be like you know and
first and foremost I wanted to spend
some time with my beautiful wife I
wanted to have a naked pizza party did
that happen that happened and then I
slowly wanted to just get back to work
but first start with the basics okay the
basics which is fitness family fun and
don't forget the finances because you
don't want to end up back in prison Mike
the situation Sorrentino is first
interview since leaving prison and only
telling et what the experience was like
the real situation in prison is not like
the movies I'll have to tell you that
okay but what I did I went to sleep
every night at 10:00 p.m. I woke up
every morning at 7 a.m. and did fasted
cardio for about an hour
I was practicing intermittent fasting
while I was in prison I had to
continually challenge myself whether it
was in the gym or endor diets as well as
reading books and trying to progress you
know spiritually as well because if you
do not keep yourself busy in there I
don't hands up for the devil the Jersey
Shore star served an eight month
sentence in New York after pleading
guilty to tax evasion yeah I feel like
you were hanging by a thread no no I
didn't feel like I was hanging for a
thread I just felt that everything in my
life had prepared me for this journey
and although very uncomfortable I lived
one day at a time every single day you
know try to be my best self or better
than the day before
and then move forward and that was it
and I'll be honest which I was very
successful and by no means was it a
comfortable situation being one day away
from your loved ones is unacceptable but
it's manageable
you can survive it how would you rate
the food one to ten it is probably like
the worst school lunch you've ever had
and if you're trying to lose weight and
get healthy it could be almost
impossible what did you miss the most
the thing that I missed the most was
probably my beautiful wife next to me
you sort of take your freedom I would
say for granted sometimes and once it is
sort of taken away from you you're
taking advantage of once you get out not
necessarily every minute but every
second every meal every conversation I
cherish with my beautiful wife with my
friends I love my job so I feel like I'm
on such an awesome road and we're very
excited to see what the future has to
offer you mentioned you're grateful for
every meal I know yeah that was your
last meal before you went to prison
let's reverse meal out
the last meal was probably I probably
was ordering some sort of fast food
delivery because I was you know ordering
everything you know when you realize
that your freedom is being taken away
from you you're like you know what I'm
not gonna get good food in prison so I'm
gonna order McDonald's I'm gonna order
Wendy's I'm going chick-fil-a we're
turning up and living our best life and
I did that and I you know I gained a
couple pounds but I had the time once I
was in prison to concentrate on being my
best self and you know losing the weight
are you a changed man do you feel like
you're a changed man I definitely feel
like I'm a changed man you know it
really starts with my recovery though
I'll be honest with you I'm four years
clean and sober in a couple months and I
just practice you know living one day to
table being my best self and you know
making sure that I'm you know the best
man I could be for my beautiful wife you
know the best son to my mother you know
best friend to my friends out there and
do the best job I can it work and and
then after that let go on that God
handle it have you seen the cast since
you were released yeah yeah we we saw
the cast what was it a day after yeah I
think the day after it was a day after
we went straight to work
[Music]